mauvaise manoeuvre malaise du pilote ou
même geste volontaire
les enquêteurs du bureau de la sécurité
des transports britannique n'écarte
aucune possibilité ici nathalie cloutier
radio canada montréal élections
fédérales si l'équipe libérale remporte
ces élections elle s'engage à négocier
une nouvelle entente avec les provinces
sur le financement de la santé
c'est ce qu'affirme le chef de saintes
rude au premier à répondre aux demandes
du premier ministre philippe couillard
quant au chef du npd attaqué sur tous
les fronts il a répondu aux
conservateurs qui l'accusent d'être un
imposteur des nuits de principe
tomasz le cas s'est vu forcé de défendre
ses convictions sociales démocrates leur
rente et rien que notre bonne foule pour
thomas mulcair cette fois à saint jérôme
le chef néo-démocrate poursuit sa
tournée canadienne dans les
circonscriptions clés pour convaincre
les électeurs qu'il est prêt à prendre
le pouvoir et on va continuer de
marteler ce message d'espoir de ce qu'on
peut réussir en sambre
thomas mulcair galvanise ses troupes et
les prépare à melon campagne électorale
mais il doit aussi se tenir sur la
défensive et répondre aux attaques de
ses adversaires
la dernière en lice cette publicité des
conservateurs qui le traite d'un poster
et l'accusent de tenir un double
discours sur les syndicats mais pour le
chef néo-démocrate ccim que la campagne
qu'il mène depuis 21 jours est sur la
bonne voie c'est une signe de désespoir
quand décision qui sortent des attaques
sont devenues comme ça les gens sont
capables de les juger eux le public jugé
très très sévèrement la personne qui se
livrent à ce genre d'attaqués quant aux
libéraux et lui reproche de ne pas avoir
tout dit au canadien cette semaine en
promettant un million de places en
garderie à 15 $ et moins d 1 des p2
nachos ils n'ont pas précisé que les
gouvernements provinciaux aurait à
fournir plus de 3 milliards de dollars
pour faire fonctionner leurs plans
critique ce candidat libéral ils
promettent la même chose depuis 30 ans
répond thomas mulcair
mais n'y sont jamais arrivés
le npd promet d'en faire sa priorité
mais quand vient le temps d'endosser
l'étiquette du candidat de la gauche
canadienne
thomas mulcair se fait hésitant et
refuse de répondre directement aux
questions des journalistes
je le sais social démocrate qui
travaille avec acharnement pour un nez
de l'enfant au niveau social
environnemental et économique des
politiques progressistes qui vont aider
les gens à gauche ou à droite
le chef du npd doit s'attendre à de
nouvelles attaques de ses adversaires
quand à la place qu'il souhaite occuper
sur l'échiquier politique ici laurent
terrière radio canada montréal